and i'm coming to realize that oh my
goodness like the western society has
made this islam like a blood shedding
killing like like all the pieces were
coming together like like i i wasn't
aware of of islam but i guess uh you
know the media they make the the
middle eastern men with you know they
wear the turbans and the the
they can dress but obviously
like they make those men seem like those
are the two
they'll kill and so i'm connecting the
dots and i'm like wait a minute no
they're not
they're not that they're muslims and
they're
they don't want to hurt anybody
and
why is
why does the world not know about this i
i have the truth in my heart i still
have hardship and i still go through you
know hard things every single day i face
the struggle but
but when you know you know and i have
the truth in my heart so i'm hungry
today we are joined with another very
special guest you might recognize her
from tick tock youtube and other places
where her lovely clips are being shown
this is muslim brooklyn salaam sister
how are you doing
today it's a good day we haven't had any
rain here in texas in months and the
last two there's it's flooding it's
literally flooding in dallas so
there's lots of uh lots of life coming
down literally
speaking of blessings you're just
telling us that allah has blessed you
with opportunity to give two people
their shahadas on live
and i can't help but wonder how did
muslim brooklyn become muslim and how
did it get to this point so why don't
you tell us a little bit about your
story and how it got to this point we're
giving shahada's life
it's
it's definitely like
a crazy
you know story like who would think this
this uh
white girl country girl from arkansas
oklahoma
i grew up in a town a tiny town of 900
people guys little country town not even
the stoplight in the on the road
you know and the whole town is
christian uh does everybody really
practice and go to church every sunday
no but um
i've never i never seen a muslim uh
in my life until i was 25 i did not know
uh i did not know that there were
muslims and that they follow a religion
called islam
um i never seen a woman wrapping her
head
of course when i became muslim i started
seeing them everywhere i was like where
have you guys been
they've been there everywhere but
i um
growing up
i i went to church the same church my
whole life a southern baptist
in uh in this small town i'm from and
you know
i
i tried to read the bible like i i tried
to
focus in on it but i could never like
i could never understand what it was
saying and even when i went to church
no matter if i was not tired going in
church every time i would be falling
asleep listening to this man speak up
what are you saying
anyways
i always believed in god i always prayed
at night before i went to bed
and
it was i'm not gonna lie it was uh
hard growing up as a little girl i
didn't have my mother or my father
so my my father actually passed away
when i was like
two months old and my mother subhanallah
she was you know going through you know
her own thing and she just wasn't there
you know
the struggle like of
violence drugs i just seen a lot as a
little girl and so i had i had no love
and nobody to show me i had no guidance
from from the people that were around me
so i always turned to god i always
prayed to the heavenly father
you know
please guide me to the straight path
in jesus name i pray amen and that is
literally the prayer that i prayed until
i was like five to 25 years old
and i just never stopped asking for that
guidance i knew that
i knew that it could always be worse
don't get me wrong that's i was very
grateful but i just knew that if my
creator was guiding me
then
if i'm homeless if i'm poor if i have
nothing as long as i'm being guided
then
inshallah then i'll be okay and i don't
know why
i really look back on this and i think
how did i
how did i know to even ask for guidance
i don't remember anyone teaching me this
i just continuously every time i prayed
i never asked for god give me money or
god give me nice clothes or this i just
please guide me please guide me i wanted
to be guided and
subhanallah like
i don't know once i once i like got into
my teenage years i remember one day at
school uh we were eighth grade and we
were talking the conversation of the
bibles came up and these boys these
girls everybody's like
the bible has to have been changed like
it's not the br it's not the
the same bible that when it was like
created and
i remember thinking about that and i'm
like yeah like it wouldn't make sense
that you know people have kept rewriting
it and translating it re-editing it and
just
it's definitely not
what it should be and so
i kind of started drifting away i
stopped kind of going to church i still
went just not as much
and
about 19 years old i started
like i don't think i'm really religious
anymore because i don't believe i needed
to go to church to have a connection
with god
because i always kept praying and i knew
allah was with me there so
basically um
yeah like
i didn't even know about islam i was not
looking for islam i was not looking for
a religion i wasn't really looking for
that
i don't know
i i actually went through a phase about
20 years old when i was like believe in
the universe like not really believing
in the universe because i still was
praying every night to god but
like law of attraction and
if you want it you can like if you
believe you can receive and manifest it
and you know ask the universe and it
will it will provide like
that was like a little two-year thing
and
that's really when i was like
lost started going i was really gonna
like what i was doing for my work was
very hard on what i was i was involved
in just sin and i was
i was glorifying it i wanted to get rich
and famous i wanted to i wanted to do my
raps i wanted to start like showing
people what i could do so i could get
filthy rich and then i could give it
away because i really did want to help
people i wanted to feed people i wanted
to really help the world i didn't know
how i was supposed to do that unless
i guess maybe i use what god gave me as
talent to
to succeed i guess but
either which way to wrap that up to wrap
it up i
was 25 years old and
i
uh was still praying the same prayer
dear heavenly father please guide me the
straight path in jesus name i pray amen
and um
[Music]
growing up i didn't really know if jesus
could hear me
like because he's supposed to be like a
part of the trinity
but i knew that only one could hear me
so it was really confusing it was
obviously like there's so many questions
like why is jesus the son of god how
come moses can't be the son of god or
abraham ibrahim islam like
why why does jesus get that status so as
a christian i just had so much confusion
and when you ask questions to the church
they say just have faith because this is
where blind faith comes in
anyways i
i met a
muslim brother and
i
i was like
this guy is like sincere like i've never
met somebody like this like he was just
so nice and
respectful and didn't make me feel
uncomfortable and
one day we started talking about god and
he asked me like about prophets and what
do i believe about god and
he told me what he believed which is you
know god is only one
and jesus and all these prophets they
were they were prophets
and i said that's what i believe
and
you know the angels the the holy books
and the day of judgement i said yeah
i know this like as a christian we
believe this but he just had so much
more details to the story
i did some research a couple of weeks
later i became muslim i gave up my job
my haram job i gave it up the music the
rapping the glorifying my sins i gave it
up
i
i said
he told me if you give up something for
allah for god then he will give you
something way better
i gave it up two weeks later i was
muslim he said
we are here it's two and a half years
later and
i i have the truth in my heart i still
have hardship and i still go through you
know hard things every single day i face
the struggle but
but when you know you know and i have
the truth in my heart so i'm hungry for
a smile
so it seems like it was something that
was really smooth in the beginning was
there anything in particular that really
stood out to you about islam where
you're like okay this is the truth
yes so the thing was that i did not i
was so ignorant as a christian i thought
you know growing up like
you know
it wasn't easy but i still like had this
sense of i'm special god loves me i knew
god loved me but like not in like an
arrogant way but
loki in an arrogant way because i was
like if you're not christian see it's
it's so ironic because even though i had
all these confusions and questions about
christianity
i still in the back of my head was like
if you're not christian then you're
wrong you must believe in some other god
i was so ignorant i did not even know
that there was a i didn't know that
there were three abrahamic faiths see
they don't teach you this as a christian
but in islam i've learned more about
christianity in two and a half years
than 20 years of being a christian
so yeah like
basically
and this is why i like to talk to the
christians so much about the prophets
because that is what brought me to
realization that
wait a minute there's another religion
that also believes in jesus
but not as a son of god or god
um
just a prophet i believed like like the
bible says
so
i was it honestly it was it was a
mind-blowing experience like i truly was
speechless because in my head i'm i'm
like how did i not know this how did
nobody tell me this and then as i'm
learning as he's kind of telling me
about this
and i'm coming to realize that oh my
goodness like the western society has
made this islam like a bloodshed feeling
like like all the pieces were coming
together like like i i wasn't aware of
islam but i guess
you know the media they make the the
middle eastern men with you know they
wear the turbans and the the they are
dressed but obviously
like they make those men seem like the
terrorists those are the dealers and so
i'm connecting the dots and i'm like
wait a minute no they're not
they're not that they're muslims and
they're
they don't want to hurt anybody
and
why is
why does the world not know about this
so it kind of just was like all in my
head i'm bringing everything together
and then i then i stopped and i'm like
wait a minute
i'm like
god
is this the guidance that i've been
praying for my entire life
after like those two couple weeks
i guess it just like
i don't i really don't remember like
that moment when i was like i'm supposed
to be muslim but i just kept like
i kept questioning i kept asking god
like is this the guidance is this the
guidance because i knew that allah was
going to bless me with something one day
because i didn't have no i had nothing i
was always so poor i was moving from
house to house and i was moving from
family to family and i
i was just so lost and like
so
i but i knew i just knew i don't know
why i knew this but just i knew that one
day
god was gonna give me something that was
like very special and so
i just kept asking like is this the
guidance it's just the guidance and
i don't know like it's just in my heart
like i
i just felt like allah was finally like
yes this is it like
i was being pushed towards it like this
is it this is it this is it and it was
beautiful and i wanted to know more i
wanted to know more and it was like i'm
a sponge just soaking up all of islam
and i won't be able to soak it all up
until i die but like until then i just
want to i just want the world to know
the
truth so that's beautiful and allah says
in the quran that do they think they'll
say that they believe and that they
won't be tested so my question to you is
and and of course i don't say this in an
arrogant way because everyone has
difficulties right but what were some of
the biggest difficulties or hurdles that
you've had after accepting because it's
one thing to say to shahadah and become
a muslim but then to internalize that
identity it's enough
yeah of course um
honestly
so um
like
it was it was a couple of months
actually prior to becoming muslim that
uh you know i had been doing the music
thing for about three years like i had i
had gained like
25 000 followers on instagram and
i was like really putting like i was
putting my name out there i was doing
shows and i was really glorifying like
my sins like i
was
you know i was around drugs and i was
drinking and
i was you know like i really was never a
person to like be going out to parties i
never was like that i like to stay at
home
but
like i said the job that i worked was
basically that environment so
i was really into all of that that you
guys see the people like in the in the
dunya
just drowning in this done now like the
party the drugs the everything like i
was completely in the deepest hole of
that and so but the beautiful thing
about it is is that
it was two months before i became muslim
that i was like
i started getting really sad and i was
like you know what i don't i don't want
to i don't want to talk about this stuff
in my raps anymore i don't wanna
i don't wanna keep
talking about my sad life
like this is depressing
my intention was to inspire people and
show you that like
look a
a girl from nothing can really make
herself something but
i just felt like this wasn't the way
anymore and so
i stopped i just stopped writing i just
stopped writing rhymes i just stopped
and i was like the time will come and
and inshallah like the right positive
things will come and i'll be able to
talk about those things
and um
so then you know two months later i
became muslim
and
um
like it was very easy actually hungry
left for me i stopped drinking i stopped
doing all i just stopped doing
everything like
you know
it was very easy for me because i i
realized i don't know like something
just clicked in me that was like
like i had a connection with god that i
never had before and like if you don't
have that connection you really don't
even know what i'm talking about because
like truly like
my whole life was just a 180 flip boom
like
and it was easy for me
but the struggles of course i still
struggle like
what do i struggle with i mean
i don't know like i struggle with my
family and my friends i think that my
family and my friends they think that
i'm like brainwashed because when i
first told them about you know allah
they're like they're so confused they're
like
they're like uh they started like
leaving me on red i was sending them
like messages on group messages like i
just really have like three good friends
i would send them these because when i
found a psalm on my guys like look what
i found like you know uh in the quran
when prophet ibrahim
is talking to his father and he's saying
you know i
there's been guidance that hasn't come
to me that hasn't reached you yet and
like when when i read that i'm like
that's literally how i felt i'm like
i ran home i was not like worried or
embarrassed i ran home i was like guys
i'm muslim we need to be muslim like
christianity is not it
and
they were just like
like they don't
i put the head wrap on it was like they
were scared to be around me they didn't
know who i was anymore i'm like
so i had to take it off so for them to
even be comfortable around me
but
and they still are weird around me but i
don't know like that's really my biggest
struggle as a reaver my biggest struggle
was my family and my friends i'm not
close with them uh
but inshallah like i know that they see
a difference in me i know they see the
difference like and it's been two and a
half years now
and you know
it's like first they hate you
then they fight you but then they start
being curious because you're being
consistent that's what i want all river
uh muslims to understand
first they may hate you
and they're gonna they're gonna fight
you
but if you just keep on it because i do
see like like one of my cousins
she asked me about you know what do
muslims believe about jesus
oh yeah here we go like finally i'm
getting some some leverage
but um
she ended up it kind of was like a but
see little things like that will come up
i have actually a really good friend um
that she was
you know i was trying to tell him about
islam like i said they just kept leaving
me on red like they just stopped they
stopped talking to me and um
she they she straight up told me like
i know my relationship with god and
that's not it i'm like you don't even
know what that is like it was so sad you
know but then but then the last time i
saw her
she asked me why do you keep saying that
every time i do anything
she was like why do you keep saying that
said bismillah you know in the name of
god the name of allah you do these
before you do you say that before you do
things and you know like there'll be
blessing in it and because you know you
do everything for opal
and
she was like
you know like
she even asked me another question i'm
like see so like
they might hate you and they might fight
you and they might be so like confused
at you but
with time inshallah may allah guide us
all and i think that i truly believe
that
allah is going to you know make some of
my family
hopefully all of them but i think that
there are people in my family that they
are gonna allah's gonna open their
hearts so biggest struggle is family and
friends
not and you know not being
uh not so much my family and friends
anymore in that
don't forgive me for this
but definitely like i think this is
amazing thus far and you know i'm gonna
view it myself
so i one thing that i wanted to throw
out here that i've noticed with you and
with all the all the other rebirths
is that it's like a lot brings us to our
lowest point
before we actually embrace islam
because i myself had to come to the
lowest lowest lowest point in my entire
life before i was like
okay it is i gotta do something i gotta
do something so i just want to say i
noticed that i'm very intrigued i want
to hear more about the story so i'll
definitely tune into
this podcast video once we have it
recorded and we have it up
but that being said may love bless you
and
fill your life with barakah
and assalamu alaikum
thank you very much
okay yeah so
first question that comes to my mind is
did you have a preconceived notion
before islam
no um i i just wanted to tell you about
there was um you know how they talk
about after 9 11 basically was when all
the media propaganda stuff started
happening like
um
i guess see and that's what i'm like i
guess i wasn't really paying attention
to it
but that that just shows you that even
though i wasn't really paying attention
it was still affecting me because the
first time i ever got on an airplane i
was uh 21 years old
and i
i got on the airplane and i saw um a man
muslim muslim muslim he was in a white
bulb a turbine on his head and it's not
that it was because that's a muslim or
that's a you know i like i guess that
maybe maybe uh
without realizing it seeing on tv how
they portray these uh you know men on
that side of the world that's what i got
to sting in my heart i got scared like
because they i know what it is because
they're always talking about like those
are the men like those are the type of
men that did 9 11. so
you know they're always gonna want to
try to bomb the plane i'm like
yo so i had to i had to think about that
and realize it but it was never like
muslims are that
um people that follow i did not i
literally did not know that there was a
religion called islam and um a lord or
um i didn't know like the jews were also
like that we believe all the pretty much
the same prophets like i really was that
ignorant i did not have those conceived
notions at all
yeah so i wanna i wanna say something
when you said the airplane thing i wanna
i wanna let you know that i'm a born
muslim like rami but we didn't really
come to islam until later in our life
right just like just like you and
brother on health so we're similar in
that sense but despite being the most
being a born muslim
when i went on an airplane i saw someone
that was dressed in like the arab way
and i had those same thoughts too
and it just goes
now even though i was going into islam
how much the brainwashing programming
and the conditioning that we have in
western media has affected me in a
subconscious level because it wasn't
that instant that i didn't realize it
but that that begs another question
though aside from that did how did you
how was your perception of islam towards
women specifically and how did that
change because a lot of people a lot of
feminists they think that islam is a
religion that favors men and not women
right right um honestly and and i'm
being 100 honest i literally i didn't i
hadn't i hadn't ever seen a muslim woman
i had never seen a woman uh covering her
hair
definitely not in uh like in person um
if i did see it maybe on tv or something
i uh you know i don't remember i truly
don't remember so i think that was like
that was the thing when i was learning
you know islam
at the first
it was it was coming to me like like i
guess
like subconscious thoughts and things
that i had seen were kind of coming to
me and i'm realizing like i'm putting
the puzzle pieces together like oh
you know uh
like and
there it's not that like there are these
middle eastern people are bad like
they're attributing this to muslims i
was realizing oh they've been talking
about muslims this whole time this is
what people try to make you know the
western world is trying to
make everybody think that these people
want to hurt us
and that's just not the case like i
remember asking was like
how does the world not know about islam
and to keep to keep it on like muslim
women actually because of my job and
what i was doing
you know i actually got a lot of
attention because of my physical
appearance a lot of attention from male
and females
a lot of people
would would come up to me and and and
literally asked me like i literally
can't tell you how many times this
happened in my life like is your hair
real like is your hair real how do you
get it like that like oh my you're so
pretty like i and alhamdulillah like you
know of course as humans be like
attention and for a little while for
like a couple years it was cool like
no thank you like it kind of boosted my
confidence because i never was the cute
girl i was never the pretty girl and i
was never the popular girl i was i was i
was the one that was trying to fit in
that would really do the most uh
you know i would i would i would i would
try to go and get these expensive i
would have a hundred dollars and i could
have i could have bought a whole bunch
of new clothes at walmart
but no i would go to the mall just to
get two shirts and a pair of jeans so i
can look cool like that girl like i was
that girl i'm not gonna be shy about
telling you guys that am i that girl now
absolutely not because that's really
what
when um
when i when i accepted islam and i'm
seeing that
okay these women what they cover their
hair and it's not like i had a bad
thought about it i really was like why
and when i you know obviously it's
because allah tells us so allah commands
the woman to be modest and men to be
modest and cover yourselves and and um
basically because of my job and because
of the
the attention and the fake attention
that i would get
um
i realized that
people people only talk to me because of
like
they think i'm you know
and so you see that okay men are only
talking to me because
they want you know what and then women
will it's crazy because girls it's so
sad that females are like this and um we
will we will
i i truly don't feel like i've ever been
like this um but girls will you know
you're so pretty and and then like after
they tell you that it's like they become
envious and jealous of you and then they
treat you a different way or you got the
girls that will give you like the stink
eye like
and so
learning about hijab immediately
immediately i was like
i saw the uh i saw the wisdom in it and
i immediately like i put on a bandana
like i didn't wear a complete hijab at
first but i put on a bandana and i was
like because
yeah like i was i would i got tired of
people just coming up to me because of
my hair like it really was just like i
saw the wisdom in the hijab and you know
what a lot i just want to say because
maybe there are some muslim born muslim
sisters watching rebirth sisters
watching i want you to please
please hear me
when you live the philosophy
you understand the wisdom maybe you
don't want to wear hijab you don't
understand you want to you want to feel
like
whatever you want to feel like
trust me if you just fulfill the
commandment if you do what allah says if
you live the philosophy
then you'll understand the wisdom behind
it and then inshallah you will
appreciate it and and then i will make
it easy for you and i know that that has
happened with me
and so i just i pray for all my muslim
sisters that may allah make it easy for
us
our journey to becoming more modest
um you know at first i wanted to put on
hijab but i was like not really that
comfortable to put on like java
now i just want to go everywhere in my
jill bob i'm like i feel like a queen in
that thing you know so
please muslim sisters like
you are most beautiful you are most
beautiful most protected inshallah when
you are covered
i mean
i mean i mean
and uh did you ever come across
common reaper struggles like doubts and
stuff like that because for me as
someone that found islam later in my
life there were phases where i come
across channels like you know david wood
and obviously now we have an almost
respect and they've been reputations but
it's like as someone that's not learning
you come across that and you're like oh
my god like it's true so did you have
anything similar
i do have one thing i do have one thing
that
because
i said that i never knew muslims right
but actually when i became muslim
i found out that i did know one muslim
sister
um but she didn't ever tell me she was
muslim so there was no way for me to
know she was
but um
i heard her say one day like
praying to allah she said something
about praying to allah and i was like
you know this is like
four years before i began muslim i'm
like praying to allah you know this is
my ignorance
who's the law i was like i pray to god
you know like
and so
basically fast forward when i became
muslim
you know my husband um
at the time he was not my husband but he
would always say you know allah he would
always refer to god as allah and
sometimes he would say god but i noticed
that when he would say allah
i would kind of feel like
because i said dear heavenly father my
whole life and i actually when i prayed
i didn't even like saying the word god
because i felt like it was just so like
there was nothing to it you know like
rappers call themselves gods so i'm like
god it doesn't really hold that much
weight to me so i would always be like
dear heavenly father so when i heard
this word allah i was just so uneducated
and so ignorant that i
i was like
it was it was hard for me at first to
start praying to allah
but i did it i did it i started
immediately i was like allah you know i
started using the word allah when i when
i would pray
and it yeah it was a couple of months
two three months went by of being of
being a muslim
and i yeah i had i remember one day i
started having a doubt in my head
and i'm like
i made a mistake like am i praying to
like someone different you know because
people like people on comments and you
know islamophobes they'll be like oh
muslims pray to the moon god and i'm
like
now i'm like you believe there's a moon
god like you really think that no
there's only one god like but at the
time i'm like did i make the right
decision you know like i started getting
this little like
no like
no i'm i've made the right decision like
i truly i think back on it and i think
yeah that was shake on trying to get
into my head tell me that oh have you
made the right decision like are you are
you really praying to god are you
praying to some other god no no no allah
that was that was the light of allah and
he came and showed me that only he can
guide like
he came to me but then i drifted away
from him and it's like
only truly only a law can like save us
only allah can die and allah is only one
like after seeing that yeah it's like
there's no trinity we gotta stop saying
trinity there's no uh son of a holy
spirit no it's just
allah is only one and then
and i think that's probably when i read
the quran because i didn't read quran uh
until after becoming muslim so when i
read the quran and i realized that allah
actually calls himself allah like that
is all that is god's name and i think i
think back i'm like in christianity we
don't have a name for god if you really
think about it like what do christians
call god i guess some call jesus like
yahweh or whatever but
most christians i know like say dear
heavenly father like you don't even have
a name for god i thought that was
something that was really like
kind of you know mind-boggling so
alhamdulillah that that was really my
only doubt but then after that after
that dream i truly was like no like i
made the right decision and so now
you know it's not to say that i have
those same doubts or any like just
sometimes maybe if i have like a a
moment of low iman i go back to that
dream and i think about allah like
coming to save me and and um
literally saving me from the darkness
like and i just wanted to relate that to
like the dunya because you know we as
muslims we know that like
you know allah says in the first of the
chapter uh surah baqarah that they have
a barrier a seal over their eyes hearts
and their ears and i swear like
uh as a as a as a reaver as a
a christian before i truly i see i
understand that because i truly had a
barrier over my ears and my eyes and my
heart i remember that time when i was
deaf dumb and blind and so the fact that
i know allah has truly like once i
became muslim it's like i got brand new
eyeballs and i got brand new ears and i
got a brand new heart and i can i read
the quote on
oh my goodness when i read the quran for
the first time
i was like it just it just
the fire got bigger inside me to like
want to share islam and tell the world
about it so
yeah there's
alhamdulillah only allah can guide you
so may allah got all the muslims and the
non-muslims i mean
i mean
rummy bro do you want to jump in yeah
yeah i was going to ask it's always that
when you know after most after brooklyn
became muslim is that when she became
muslim brooklyn when you wanted yourself
so i was gonna i was wondering if you're
gonna ask me about this um nobody's ever
asked me like where why do you call
yourself muslim brooklyn i don't know if
you guys um know about this uh brother
and he he he's a reaper and he used to
try to do i think i think i remember
correctly he wanted to be like a artist
a rap artist but then he became muslim
and he calls himself
and he makes like he makes uh what are
they called like nasheeds now like
really good ones
and so that's actually where i got
muslim brooklyn i had like my name is
brooklyn with a b and i was like
oh it's not like i was trying to like
come up and be like a rapper
of islam no no like i was kind of i was
like done with the music thing because
once i became muslim i realized like
yeah the music thing is like maybe
inshallah in the future i'll be able to
do some like a nice written spoken word
or something inshallah if it comes
that's not really where my mind is but
um
yeah when i i i just wanted to share
videos i just wanted to read these books
of about islam to the people and i i
when i made tick tock i said what should
my name be and i came across muslim
bilal and i said
i'm going to be muslim brooklyn so i'm a
muslim brother
you just call me brooklyn but yeah
i mean let me let me ask you a question
you don't have to answer if it's too
personal but you mentioned you had a not
the best relationship with you growing
up right and you lost your mother when
you were young so how has that
relationship changed after you became
muslim
um i think you cut out with my mom did
you say my mom yeah so how did that
relationship with the woman change after
you became muslim
yeah basically um basically my mom i was
not around her for the first 23 years of
my life like
like she lived she lived like 45 minutes
away from me but i just never i
maybe once
a year like i would get to like i would
i would go see her but
she just really was going through her
own struggle and trials that it wasn't
like a mother-daughter relationship at
all so but um
uh i started talking to her more about
23 years old i kind of started talking
to her more because she finally got
clean muhammad illah my mom my mom she
finally like got off of uh you know all
the things that she was doing
and i think it's because my brother died
i have an older brother and a little
sister my older brother he he went to
prison for 10 years and a month after he
got out he died in a car crash that was
like three years ago now so
um
so basically like i didn't even get to
see him and that was really hard for my
mom i know even though my mom didn't
raise my brother either it was obviously
really hard for her and i was like i
can't imagine that but she ended up
getting very cleaned up and we started
talking more and
you know we it was the first time that
we ever had a relationship and it wasn't
like the best one but
it you know working progress
uh so yeah around the time that i became
muslim was when obviously like we me and
my mom we were talking the most and
maybe every once every four or five
months i would go like stay a weekend
with her
and um
i i became muslim and um
a year later really like exactly one
year later is when she just kind of
started asking me questions about it and
um
she wanted she wanted to hear me out
like unlike the rest of my family she
wanted to hear me out and i told her you
know all these things about do you
believe jesus like is god son of god
like you know i tell him about the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him and
and and it made sense to her that made
sense sir and so i think a couple more
months went by and she was like i want
to read the quran and i said okay so i i
gave her a quran and she read it and
afterwards i asked her like what do you
think about it you know and she was like
well i think it's from god i don't think
anybody else could have broke this
except you know not a human it had to
have been from god
and so i was like oh yeah like i didn't
even push it on her but one day she
called me and
you know we were kind of talking about
it and i said do you believe that the
prophet muhammad is a is a prophet that
he you know that he was the final
prophet at least
she's like yeah i do i said do you want
to come do you want to be muslim mom and
she was like
i do
so alhamdulillah me and gohar we gave
her shahada and that was that was yeah
my me and my mom my whole family and
friends of all the people i know it's me
and my mom that have become muslim so
yeah
it's a good relationship now yeah
that's beautiful i respect my mom now
more and because of islam because allah
tells me so in the quran i respect her
more and you know it's it's hard for me
to she's my mom but because i just never
had that relationship with her it's more
like a it's like a friend relationship
but she's my mom and i i i'm actually it
seems like i'm the one that teaches her
i teach her and that's fine
alhamdulillah we we get along and
and
you know she watches all my videos and
she supports me and she was my biggest
supporter when i was doing music
and it was a little hard for her when i
made that transition too she wanted me
to keep making music she wanted me to
like keep doing what i was doing because
i was really making a name for myself
and
but then after about
literally here until recently maybe like
six eight months ago is when she finally
was like okay i'm glad you're not doing
music anymore i'm glad that i'm glad
that you cover and i'm glad that you
stopped you know doing that work and i'm
just
she and it finally she came to
realization alhamdulillah so
good good good good relationship with my
mom she's a blessing alhamdulillah may
allah grant her the highest i mean
so i want to ask more about your
platform when did you decide you know
this is a beautiful message and i need
to portray it to the masses i need to
tell people my story about how brooklyn
became muslim in muslim brooklyn and uh
was this before your mom converted
africa
yes so i think okay so i converted i
april 6 2020
and it was that summer like june that
you know
see in my head i'm like i have to share
this with the world like i have to tell
everybody that i can about this and
since my family and my friends weren't
listening
i had to go tell somebody so i like made
a new tick tock account and um i had a
bunch of you know like beginners books
for for reverts to
you know learn islam and so i al
hamdulillah like it's not for me this is
from allah put it in my head to just
just read from the books just just make
videos and start reading from these
books you know and and so that's what i
did and i remember the first video that
i made
the first video i made that like blew up
um i was talking about allah i said you
know muslims the reason why we call god
allah
you know it's like it's just it's just
an arabic word for the god like the one
true god like the only god that can hear
our prayers
you know it's just that you know even
arab christians they say allah and so
i just want to say like
three three and a half years of me doing
music and
um glorifying my sins
and
putting money into it making music
videos going to studio time putting
putting my heart and my my energy my
time my tears everything i was putting
so much into the music and i was losing
money i was losing my energy i was like
i was losing
what i should be like felt like i should
be gaining
three and a half years
in five minutes of talking about a lot i
gained more success than i did in three
and a half years of talking about the
dunya
subhanallah
five minutes of of making a video and
just trying to tell people like you know
like i just i just i didn't know where
to start i just like it just
okay i'm gonna make a video and i went i
went to my windowsill and
started saying you know this is why we
say allah and
it blew up like i hadn't i was like i
was it caught me off guard i did not
expect that so i just look at it as a
hunger i'm very grateful because i put
so much of myself into trying to become
an artist a recording artist that
i see now that look
it took me five minutes to make that
video and
i got so much love from all the muslim
brothers and sisters and and so much
just uh kind words and
you know obviously hate from the
christians but
period like
more success in five minutes than i did
within three and a half years like that
really is a sign to me and it should be
to other people so
yeah i just kept making the videos i
kept reading from my books and i just
wanted to tell people like the truth
so how long ago was that first video i
don't know if i missed the date
about
i think it was around june or july of
2020
wow and um yeah i i think it should
still be up on my page but at the time
uh i wasn't wearing hijab correctly so i
know at one point about a year ago or
maybe like eight months ago i had like
went through my my page and i deleted
all the videos where my neck was showing
but i think in that particular video i
have a a jacket on that was kind of high
so i think it's still on my page and
it'll be one of the very first videos i
posted about you know
allah so
has your goal of your page or maybe your
objects that you you know objectives and
what you want to talk about has that
changed since you first started so now
when you have more of a fan base have
you realized well maybe i need to start
focusing on this or has it remained the
same
um i would say that like
um it's the same but the thing like as
you know i
i listen to podcasts and i listen to
gullum institute podcast like
all day every day like i it was very
easy for me to give up music which is
crazy because i was making music i felt
like it gave me life but i was it very
quickly i was like
i could be learning about allah and his
messenger
and
i'm i'm
i'm like killing my brain with this
music so i listen to podcasts and
everything all the time and i've learned
that muslims should give dawah to
muslims first if we become better
muslims and we share the you know the
beauty of islam
with other muslims then the non-muslims
will be attracted to that and they will
they will want to come towards it so
it's kind of like a it's kind of a
struggle for me like i want to like you
know i really want to help muslims
become better muslims which will help
myself become a better muslim obviously
first but um
but i just feel like
i feel like because i was a christian
like if they're gonna listen to anybody
especially like the girls like
maybe i
can relate with them the best and so
that is why i do like i speak about
christianity so much it's not so much
like oh i got more followers now i
should do this or like or like i i
really like i really i try hard to keep
my intention like i just need to share
islam i just need to share the truth i
just want to keep making videos and and
because if if i for 25 years didn't know
about islam and i and i didn't know that
allah was you know just like another
name for that we call out to god as like
then i know that there's
millions and millions and millions of
more people because just the town that
i'm from the people that are there
they they look at me and they're so
confused they don't know what's going on
so i just like every day my motivation
when i make videos is to just share
islam share the truth share the truth
for the sake of allah and may allah you
know open the hearts of those who
are that don't know i just i just want
people to know so
inshallah um
inshallah i try to bring christians to
islam and i truly want to
um
it's not that i started wanting to
inspire muslims i i truly like i just
wanted to talk to the christians i just
want to tell the christians like look
this is what this is what it is but then
i started getting born muslims i guess
really looking up to me they like to
hear uh they like to see me and they're
like you know you motivate me to be a
better muslim and so alhamdulillah
that's great that's beautiful and so
inshallah i can keep doing that for the
sake of allah always but but but my
intention uh rami is usually to just i
just want the people that don't know
islam to know islam and maybe there's
more muslims that kind of drift away
because i feel like this is normal
any religion that you're in unless
unless you have like you know strong
religious muslim parents
and you don't have and they you know if
they don't have that guidance in that
like
uh example
then even muslims born muslims they can
maybe in sha allah and and and
see that
islam is the only thing on this earth
that matters islam allah and in his
messenger sallallahu alaihi
is the most important thing all this
dunya going around us
it's bs guys do not fall into it do not
fall into the trap it's literally all a
trap
and i've lived the life so please take
it from me do not go put these tattoos
on you do not go and think that you need
to like go and be out with your friends
and do this to party and have fun like
that's not the way it's not the way like
your life can be over tonight
and only allah
is important just please remember that i
want people to just know that
i you know i was going to ask as the
final question do you have a message for
the viewers but i feel like you
discussed it
and i do want to say to the viewers
smash that like button if we can get 5
000 likes on the stream inshaallah will
invite sister brooklyn for a live q a
i don't know if you're ready for that
but inshallah the questions and then you
can just answer on the spot
yes guys run up the likes and yes i mean
i i hope that
i may allah bless you all the brothers
the three muslims and uh may allah
increase you and grant you all the
success in this world and the next and i
truly pray that allah increases you with
your iman all the muslims all the
muslims please just pray for allah to
increase our iman our ibadah make it
easy for us and and and let's continue
to grow with our knowledge of allah's
perfect deen let's try our best to
follow
prophet muhammad the last and final
messenger that god sent and then that
includes ibrahim and noah moses jesus
they all set good examples for humans
the same god said every single one of
them and if we just try to learn from
them
learn from them don't learn from
from your friends don't learn from these
you know these instagram models it's not
it you guys like a lot his perfect dean
islam is the only thing that matters and
may allah help
guide us all and just make it easy for
us to follow it i mean i mean allah i
mean
foreign
the prophet saw mentioned that the
bridge between belief and disbelief is
abandoning salah if you're struggling
with your salah right now well we got
the perfect solution for you and that
solution is the adan app this cell phone
we usually have it and is using us
instead of us using it
but with the adan app you can use it in
perfect alignment with your life the
adan app is already used by 40 million
believers around the world why because
it caters to your islamic lifestyle on
top of this a lot of times you get your
eyes
the islamic calendar ramadan calendar
suhur and iftar times
hajj and umrah guide qibla finder
and much more for free so download the
adonap now